John: So what?
Her parents are believing
that their straight daughter brought home
her lesbian friend for Christmas?
Abby: They also think that I'm,
that I'm straight.
John: Have they ever met a lesbian?
Clea DuVall: My name is Clea DuVall
and I am the director and
co-writer of Happiest Season.
I am a huge fan of holiday movies,
and I also love rom-coms,
but I had never seen my
experience represented
in those genres.
But then once I started, you know,
transitioning from acting into writing
and directing, it kind of hit me
that I could be the person
who could tell that story.
You know, it's a romantic
comedy and you know,
it needs to have those
like big comedic moments.
Man: From where?
Abby: I'm really not interested
in meeting anyone tonight.
Jane: I am.
Clea: Harper's family, you know,
kind of was born from that.
Just like, what is the family
that you're gonna go
home to in this situation
and it's going to just be-
Abby: Everyone say Christmas.
Tipper: No, don't say that just smile.
Clea: The most uncomfortable.
Tipper: Blurry, boring.
Nope, nope, nope.
Okay.
None of these will do, we
will try again tomorrow.
Clea: Came out to my mom on Christmas day,
we were in the middle of a fight
and it just flew out of my mouth.
Me saying something along the line
of "You don't know me at all,"
and then my mom saying, "Yes, I do."
And then me saying, "Well,
yeah, but did you know
so and so is my girlfriend?"
And then both of us freezing
and being like, oh, oh
no, what just happened?
And then after what felt
like three and a half hours
my mother just saying,
"No, I didn't know that."
And then walking out of the room
and then we just never
talked about it again.
We were able to repair it.
So that was like the good news.
It was not great until later in life
when I got into my twenties.
Tipper: What are you doing in the closet?
Clea: What was so important
to me in this story
was to not vilify anyone.
Abby: So Sloane and Eric, you
guys make gift baskets, right?
Sloane: No.
We create curated gift experiences
inside of handmade reclaimed wood vessels.
Clea: 'Cause coming out
is not an easy thing to do
no matter who you are, no
matter where you come from,
we all have the opportunity
to reach the other side
and you know, and still
deserve to be loved,
and deserve to be accepted
and even if the people around us
don't always handle it exactly
the right way immediately,
it doesn't mean that they can't also grow
and that they can't also change.
Every queer person has gone through it
and you know, knows what
that feeling is of, you know,
not being out.
Wherever you are in that process,
be nice to yourself.
Like you're going through something
that is not gonna last forever
and you need to love yourself through it.
You have an idea like, I wanna
come out this holiday season,
I'm gonna do it.
And if you get there
and it doesn't feel like the
right thing, that's okay.
There's no rush.
It's also really important to
find outlets in the community,
you know, whether it's like friends,
or however young people communicate,
I don't know, TikTok.
Abby: What are you doing on your phone?
John: I left a gentleman
alone in my apartment
so I'm tracking him to
make sure he leaves.
Abby: You're tracking him?
John: Yeah. I track everybody.
If the NSA can do it, so can I.
Clea: Don't be afraid to reach out.
Our community is so amazing
and you will inevitably find support
even in places you might not expect it.
John: Yes I am John,
Abby's heterosexual ex-boyfriend,
and I have come to get her back.